je suis cassé ce bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors c'est une
date symbolique en ce 31 janvier qu'est
ce qui va réellement se passer à partir
de demain 1er février
pas grand-chose énormément lors de la
mission
en fait il n'a pas y avoir des vêtements
dans les heures à venir ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'il y aura des
négociations que j'annonce du mur entre
londres et non européenne précisément
elles vont être assez difficile à ces
discussions
tout ce qui est la politique commerciale
il y a une volonté britannique de faire
de l'europe ou simplement le grand dijon
de libre échange dans une vidéo on sonne
c'est le cheval de troie de donald trump
est le grand rêve de fonctionne c'est
que l'europe perd de sa voile politique
au profit d'une identité virement
commercial économique et financière et
puis ce qui sera lié à la finance et à
l'économie et aussi au commerce
voilà des plats de résistance qui seront
véritablement difficilement à digérer
donc en gros le feuilleton break site
n'est pas terminée c'est juste la fin
d'un premier acte je dirais que c'est
plus que la fin d'un premier acte quand
même le départ de la grande bretagne de
l'union européenne ce n'est pas rien si
vous voulez la vie divorce est là si on
prend cette image il ya divorce
mais après un divorce il ya toujours des
questions reliées bah oui et comment
garder les enfants
comment faire pour la pension
alimentaire serbe ça c'est à dire que
tout simplement le divorce est prononcé
aujourd'hui ils en ont vendu leurs 9 mai
la vie quotidienne divorce elle prend
effet on est fébrile
demain alors à ce sujet ursula von der
leyen qui est la présidente de la
commission européenne a regretté le
départ du royaume uni je veux que lui et
le royaume uni reste de bons partenaires
de bons amis c'est ce qu'elle a déclaré
est ce qu'un retour est envisageable
selon vous alors j'ai trouvé cette
déclaration extrêmement diplomatique
mais quelque part pas très belle
nous ne pouvons pas avoir d'excellentes
relations avec la grande-bretagne
quand on a eu un repère je n'ai pas
possible quand quelqu'un divorce de vous
il y à un jeune ou un passif et se
qualifie pour la finale à m avant la vie
est un peu on dirait de la cosmétique
donc aujourd'hui à potentiel retour de
la grande bretagne dans l'union
européenne nous quatre mais alors il
faudra du temps beaucoup de temps et je
n'ai pas du tout à l'ordre du jour le
leader du parti
dube rexie partie d'alpha rage a déclaré
au parti you keep et au parti breakes
site nous aimons l'europe mais nous
haïssons l'union européenne
pourquoi selon vous qu'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu justement pour qu'il y ait
pas cette haine entre l'union européenne
et londres n'a pas fallu dix chars âge
parce que la mission fera rage et le
parti du politique très bien en tout cas
merci beaucoup monsieur gilbert casasus
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur en
études européennes